[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight one of the great secrets
of washington something we don't tell
anybody outside the city is that the
only people who really benefit from the
presidential primaries are the political
consultants who work in them the
candidates themselves almost always
finish the experience sadder poor and
humiliated the public meanwhile hates
the whole thing they get to spend half a
year tormented by the white noise of
30-second attack ads only the
consultants really seem to enjoy
themselves and why wouldn't they they
walk away rich for them it's a great
deal so they've got every incentive to
recruit new suckers to the game their
latest mark is a billionaire called
Howard Schultz he's the former CEO of
Starbucks a pair of slick consultants
somehow convinced Howard Schultz that he
could be President so over the weekend
he announced he may get in the race
here's the twist Schultz who was an
entirely conventional affluent liberal
said that he is not planning to run as a
Democrat but instead as an independent
well Democrats were horrified by this
boycott Starbucks started trending on
Twitter Michael Bloomberg denounced
Schultz some of the Left were so angry
they screamed at Howard Schultz when he
went in public watch what happened at a
book event last night
[Music]
go back any ratioed on twitter go back
to Davos with the other billionaire
elite who think they know how to run the
world
well in fairness the heckler did make
some solid points the last thing we need
is another egomaniacal Davos [ __ ]
running the country into the ground if
you sincerely thought Barack Obama did a
great job as president you'd probably be
perfectly happy with Howard Schultz at
the helm the problem is nobody really
thinks that Obama did a great job as
president they just all feel obligated
to pretend he did nobody wants to be
rude about it
and yet Schultz's problems aren't really
related to what he believes his
political positions his views are really
indistinguishable from Nancy Pelosi's
views Schultz his sin is running third
party that's a threat to the one thing
that Democrats actually care about and
no it's not fighting climate change or
preserving a woman's right to choose or
even protecting those noble undocumented
migrants they're always lecturing you
about in the end Democrats are pretty
flexible and all that stuff they're just
talking points they're transactional
bargaining chips to keep their coalition
together whatever what Democrats really
want what they're not kidding about at
all is political power the right to run
things the right to be in charge power
and they want it so bad they can taste
it poor hapless Howard Schultz and his
overfunded midlife crisis just got in
their way so they have to crush him at
least one Democrat was honest enough to
admit this I have a concern that if he
did run that essentially it would
provide Donald Trump with with his best
hope of getting reelected I would
suggest to mr. Schultz to truly think
about the negative impact that that
might make well the media were watching
and taking notes even now you still hear
people refer to the press corps as
liberal but of course they're not
liberal in any recognizable sense of the
word genuine liberals but welcome Howard
Schultz into the race more candidates
more opinions more diversity of thought
may the best ideas win that's what an
actual liberal would say that's not what
the meteors saying they're not liberals
they're loyalists they're party people
diligent worker bees toiling from the
benefit of their democratic party
masters so of course they parotid the
line precisely Michelle Goldberg of the
New York Times who embodies this called
Schultz's run reckless idiocy she didn't
even mention his views about anything
she doesn't care it's irrelevant The
Daily Beast all but accused Howard
Schultz of racism because that often
works as a line of attack quote the
Starbucks music store under Howard
Schultz was painfully white read a story
today whatever it takes and of course
the dummies on TV news read their
talking points faithfully watch he may
run for president as an independent
Democrats fearing he could help
President Trump win reelection Democrats
are uneasy he could take away votes that
would go to the Democratic nominee
Democrats warned he could cost them the
White House Democrats fear that could be
disastrous for whoever is the Democratic
nominee Democrats on the Left of
freaking out today about Howard Schultz
trial ballooning this is that if he were
to split the anti-trump boat that's a
conceivable path up the middle for
Donald Trump Oh Trump might benefit well
there's another way to look at the
Democratic hysteria over Howard Schultz
getting into the race and Mark Cuban of
all people summed it up pretty well
today quote if 21 months before an
election you don't believe your
candidates platform is strong enough to
win an election with independent
candidates you might want to rethink who
you support yeah you might want to do
that maybe get some ideas that appeal to
actual vote or something like that
the irony is that the very people who
are the most upset about Howard Schultz
entering the presidential race are the
very same ones who've been yelling at
you about how vital democracy is and how
they're the defenders of democracy and
yet somehow three candidates on a single
ballot is just way too many for them you
get the strong feeling they prefer to
see just one candidate on the ballot
that way they'd win every time voters
couldn't screw it up with their dumb
opinions we've seen all of this before
many times Ralph Nader went through when
he dared to run third party in 2000 Jill
Stein experienced he when she ran in
2016
the Green Party ticket remember that
they called her an agent of Russia for
daring to do that